welcome to the D show I'm Eddie your
host thank you for tuning in another
exciting episode of Zoey's great to see
an old friend he's back with us again
former US military Air Force Major he
was trying so hard to be well actually
he was an atheist and he was trying very
hard to be a Christian he has an
incredible story that we've done in the
past but it's always great to have my
old friend dr. Brown here in the Dean
show studio we're gonna be touching upon
some great arguments that you can use
for some of your friends colleagues at
work and you know what they say you know
what just all religions a joke I don't
believe in it I don't want it I don't
believe in God it sounds kind of dumb
doesn't it silly but we're going to be
giving you some positive things that you
can go ahead and share with the people
to have them really thinking when we
come back here on Adi show don't go
anywhere
this is the
this is the thing you know this is the
days of the engine you know this is the
jewel dr. Brad Lawrence how are you my
friend I was going to give you a high
five but that's okay back on Addie shots
always good to have at all Fred back in
the studio I bet that's always good to
be here
I'm do LA now seems like yesterday see
the time is flying when you're having
fun and I think there's a lesson there
yeah
Harry's we're not here we're not here
forever that's not fair
it's really odd we come to La Allah has
given us this great opportunity to see
each other again and I always introduce
the show talking about the show that we
did originally and we wanted to talk a
little bit about a work that you have in
progress tell us about this work well
basically I became very interested in
the refutation of atheism and I
originally put together a website called
reality of God calm maybe about seven or
eight years ago and when I revisited the
subject I found that so much has
happened and that the you know the last
seven years to bring out new evidence
against atheism and it it's really very
fascinating it's fascinating to see how
scientists are leaving the entrenched
atheism and many scientists who
historically were the ones who were the
proponents of atheism
how many scientists now are gravitating
towards recognizing the existence of a
creator and giving their various reasons
for doing so what do you say to someone
that you come across or someone's asking
you have you gotten some email saying
hey I got a colleague at the University
he said I just don't believe in God well
is there any some things that you like
to say to have something really to think
plant a seed of goodness in their hearts
something that you know that can blossom
and glow later just have them something
deep and profound you know it's pretty
much in all cases I try to tell people
look there's no post
are to answer to any of these things
we're living in a day and age where
people have very short and attention
spans if they can't see it in a in a two
minute vine or if they can't see it in a
you know five minute YouTube video where
they don't want it and so I do try to
point out to people that if they're
seriously searching for the truth of
their Creator and then the next step for
the religion of truth they have to
invest some time and effort into it
mm-hmm
aside from that I try to just leave them
with things to think about for example
somebody says that they simply don't
believe in their creator I just point
out to them that the foundation the
foundational beliefs of atheism have
basically been refuted by the scientists
themselves let me give you an example
please okay
in the past the question which came
first the chicken versus the egg was
sort of a creationist argument you know
the point being well neither one could
have come first without the other so
therefore there must be a creator right
and the the atheist arguments go back to
the Big Bang and evolution or the
process of natural selection so the
Atheist argues that in the beginning
there was this singularity there was
this explosion the universe expanded and
is continuing to expand and at that you
know during the history of the billions
of years since the life evolved on on
earth as one of those just lucky planets
that had the conditions for life okay
all right fine one when I was in college
about you know thirty years ago the Big
Bang was basically a very simplistic
concept since then scientists have
defined the moment of origin of the Big
Bang as the moment of origin of mass and
energy
and time and space the modern concept of
the Big Bang is that before the Big Bang
not only did the mass and energy not
exist but time and space did not exist
so the scientists themselves have now
basically shown that before the Big Bang
I mean this is this is their belief this
is what they argue before the Big Bang
nothing existed not mass not energy not
time not space which means instead of
asking the chicken in the egg argument
which came first the chicken or the egg
you have to ask which came first mind
versus matter right think about it
everything around us is matter and
energy scientists are now telling us not
only did the matter and energy not exist
before the Big Bang but neither did
space and neither did time so where did
all of this come from you had to have
something as an origin to these things
and if it's not matter and it's not
energy and there's no time and there's
no space the origin can only be a
transcendental creator which is
basically the answer to which came first
mind versus matter mind that is what
existed before the Big Bang and it's
interesting because in our religion we
are told that Allah brought us brought
this universe into existence through his
word of creation cool be a command is a
command of intelligence a command of a
command of mind so the scientists
themselves have basically brought their
analysis of the Big Bang back to the
point where they have painted themselves
into the corner where the only thing
that could exist before the Big Bang is
a creator with
the mind the you know transcendental
ability to will something into existence
and what religion gives us that Islam
Islam is the religion that describes
exactly that form of creator very
enlightening challenge that atheists sit
through this episode don't turn out ah
food porn drugs all of the other things
that just you know take over your life
put it on hold just sit tight we're
going to have some great information
being passed along to you and let's see
and all we ask is that you have an open
heart open mind and within yourself just
just ask the one who created you to
guide you and sit tight we'll be right
back here in a DC level anyway ladies
and gentlemen this is your captain
speaking
welcome aboard flight five two three
five non-stop to London Heathrow the
temperature is 25 degrees outside and we
are expecting a fairly smooth flight
today in a few moments the flight
attendants will be passing around the
cabin to offer you hot and cold drinks
we thank you for choosing to fly with us
today and we hope you enjoy your flight
thank God it was just a dream
god I don't believe in God ladies and
gentlemen the captain has turned on the
fasten seatbelt sign
we need of Ashiya who mojo caboodle e de
anima fleecy Nana who Dean
subscribe right now
they're watching a clip here
he
I don't know if you've seen this where
there's a bunch of Legos and I'm talking
the guys putting the Legos in the bag
yeah and the bags being shaken up and
now he's pulling it out and it's
actually a plane it's been put together
and then it says by chance and there's a
aia from the verbatim word of god the
quran stating the same exact thing do
you think you were created from nothing
right did you create yourself have you
seen this I haven't seen that and it
just doesn't mean anything to me because
there's a very far reach between Lego
and yeah what we are and this is just
this is kind of another point of the
argument back in the time of Darwin
single-cells we're just a little dot on
the slide and their complexity was
completely unknown now we have what's
called the minimum gene set Haughton
theory which is basically that cell
cannot exist without a minimum of a
certain number of functioning genes and
I believe that I believe if I remember
correctly that number now is something
like 350 well and if you look at the
complexity of a gene how it is coded how
you know how it expresses itself and so
on and so forth you realize that just
the existence of a single gene is a
miracle
but 350 genes are all working together
in a cooperative fashion that you know
that gives a cell the ability to
function at the complexity that we now
know that boggles the imagination and
it's just not sufficient to say that you
know with enough time and and with
enough
you know extremities of circumstances
these things could happen
look we were talking about how science
is basically stubbing its own foot on
these matters I mean one of the
foundational experiments that was done
to suggest that you could take the
fundamental elements of our atmosphere
and combine them and make the precursors
of life were the experiments by Stanley
Miller in Harold URIs laboratory back in
I think it was the 50s okay and he took
what he thought were the fundamental
elements of the primordial earth and put
them all together in a closed
environment past a spark through it to
simulate lightning and and so on and and
then just watched it over a few weeks
and after a few weeks he analyzed the
you know the the fluid that you know
that resulted and he found some basic
amino acids and so he said haha you can
take the basic you know the basic
substances that existed in the earth at
that time and and you can put them
through the same sort of climactic
conditions that they would have been
subject to and amino acids result from
amino acids come proteins and genes DNA
data voila a cell ok the mistake
wouldn't in that is that scientists now
know that the chemicals he used as the
two to represent the primordial
environment were wrong okay he was using
he was using methane he was using
hydrogen water vapor and I think it was
co2 but in any case what they have found
is that the methane was not there the
hydrogen was not there and and basically
when they when they analyzed what what
the correct chemicals would be and put
the correct chemical mixture together
and tried to replicate the experiment it
didn't work okay
so so if you're going to if you're going
to reference these experiments and say
well this is how it happened
you have to reference the correct
experiment experiment and it goes on and
on and on I mean there there are there
are so many arguments against the
standard atheist arguments at this point
the one I like the most is just who gave
it life you can put even if you can put
everything together in a workable
construct where does the life come from
what breathes life into this thing and
you know I understand that's not a very
scientific approach but on the other
hand some people will just connect with
that argument and realize that yeah
there was a far cry between putting
things together that you know in a
mechanical way that functions like a
machine and something that has life I
tell you one of one of the arguments I
found most interesting is when I came
upon fairly recently and that was just
while reading the Quran I I saw some
passages in which a lot was pointing out
his you know him being the creator and
saying basically challenging mankind do
we not see that he created everything in
pairs and I was struck by this I was
thinking you know that's really
interesting why why is Allah pointing
out that he created everything in pairs
and using that as an argument for him
being the creator and then I realized
you know it makes sense where did the
pairing of the sexes come from I mean
even if you believe in the concept of
evolution going back to some primordial
cell that was dividing by asexual
reproduction
how did that become pairs of everything
I mean it doesn't matter whether you're
talking about
ants fish reptiles amphibians mammals
birds the fossil record of these things
goes back pairs all the way back there
is no example in any of the lines of
creation being asexual reproduction
asexual reproduction of birds reptiles
amphibians mammals fish plants and so on
so no if this was something that
happened by happenstance you would
expect to find a transition zone in at
least one of these lines of creation
where the fossils were showing asexual
reproduction all along until something
happened and they developed the two
sexes I might believe I might believe in
natural selection of a line that follows
a linear path even though the evidence
is so much against it but now you're
asking me to believe in natural
selection of the male and female
side-by-side it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense no we're going to
take a break dr. Brown really
mind-blowing when you really reflect and
you think we have more time with dr.
Brown on this exciting episode of the D
show don't go anywhere we right back
subscribed right now
you
back here on the Dean show dr. Lawrence
Brown what has been your experience
sometimes you can have a very fruitful
conversation with someone who's you know
and intellectual and you know there's
sincerely wanting another truth and
maybe they coming from a man-made
religion and it just really didn't make
sense and there are some just weird
things being associated with it and then
you tell them these these astounding
facts and it just resonates it's
something that makes sense and you can
have you dealt with this person as
opposed to the other person who just
starts mocking leaving rude comments
becoming very ignorant what have you
seen the difference between the two and
again I think it just comes back to
following your desires and the other
thing is arrogance or arrogance yeah I
mean one of the one of the things that
I've noticed that is so difficult to
deal with and it's not just atheists
although they're very good at this but
people of a variety of you know pathways
in life is just that they're committed
to what they're upon because it gives
them what they want
they're not doing what we are bidden to
do as Muslims which is to submit to the
will of our Creator they're submitting
to the will of themselves okay they they
want to certain things so they won't
accept anything that takes them away
from that and they and the other is just
arrogance just their heart their mind is
not open you can't you can't talk to
them about these things you know another
project I'm working on right now kind of
highlights this because you know
religious people believe that a house
divided will not stand I mean it is
teaching that you take from the Bible a
house divided will not stand you can't
be fighting against yourself and you
have the atheists arguing the process of
natural selection and yet when you look
at the fruit of the atheist life
everything they are doing is against
natural selection what do I mean the
process of natural selection is that the
you know the the fit individuals
propagate their genes by having a lot of
children and spreading spreading their
genes through the gene pool right the
idea is propagation of the superior
genes well atheists have the lowest
number of children if they get married
at all to begin with they have the
highest rates of fornication they have
the highest rates of abortion the
highest rates of divorce they have no
problem with anything that has to do
with fun in this life whether it is
promiscuity drugs alcohol whatever and
all of these things are destructive to
the family unit they're destructive to
reproduction for example promiscuity
brings STDs STD is bringing infertility
okay and and on and on and on if you if
you look at what atheism promotes it
promotes a life without any moral
structure and as a result it's it's a
life basically which does not conform to
the very thing that they are teaching
natural selection now the interesting
thing is that if you look at atheist in
the eye and and and say okay so
basically what you're arguing is that
it's survival of the fittest so that's
basically saying that anybody can come
off the street and kill you and steal
your wife and daughter and it's okay
because that's what that's what
evolution is all about they of course
will say no and if you speak with
atheists you'll find out that they have
a moral framework where does that come
from where where does the basic moral
framework come from it doesn't come from
evolution comes from the teachings of
the prophets doesn't it it comes from
something inside us
an internal guidance some sort of some
sort of an understanding of what's right
and wrong which is inherent do animals
have that understanding no it's all it's
all about finding food finding a mate
finding shelter okay it's it's not it's
not achieving these things by a moral
framework it's just achieving these
things by anyway okay but human beings
have morality which is something that
you don't find anywhere do you see them
also when you start in the animal
kingdom I mean I I think that Islam if
anyone takes a sincere analytical
scientific approach you see that all the
evidence is just clear that it's from
the Creator it's not man-made and when
you talk to an atheist and when you
really start to look at their beliefs
they'll start talking about you know
Martians and aliens and they really get
into some crazy sure leaves themselves
have you had first yeah yeah okay you
know because this argument of where does
life come from okay the you know the one
of them one of the prominent atheists
who is propagating his ideology he says
exactly this came from outer space okay
aliens came down and and that's that's
basically where it came from you didn't
answer the question
where did they alien get it from oh he
got it from another alien from another
alien from another alien where did it
originate from okay I mean it's we used
to make fun of this joke you know this
old woman comes to this man is teaching
religion and she says oh I mean don't
don't you understand the the earth is
all just balanced on the back of a
turtle and he says oh really well where
did the turtle come from and she said
you silly man it's Turtles all the way
down okay
well and we laugh because you know it
seems so silly and ignorant but then
here are these a theists we're basically
saying it's aliens all the way down yeah
okay I mean one alien got it from
another from another where did the life
come from to begin with you haven't
answered the question
they they cannot deal with the fact that
that the evidence of this universe is
against their own beliefs and so they
are now talking about
multiverse okay Big Bang everything
exists expanding five years ago ten
years ago whatever they used to say okay
everything's going to expanding so at
some point the gravitational pull will
lead us from extent expansion to slowing
down and then it will become the Big
Crunch everything will come back
together again one problem they found
out that the universe is is is not
slowing down the expansion is speeding
up completely blows away their concept
of the Big Bang and and then the Big
Crunch so they start retooling and they
say okay oh we've got a problem
if we're going to keep our beliefs we
have to come up with some way of
explaining how the universe is the
expansion of the universe is speeding up
and so instead of facing the reality
that something is wrong with their
theory they start coming up with
concepts like a multiverse and this and
the other thing too to try to try to
stay upon what they're about why
arrogance arrogance just a lack of
humility and following their desires the
one thing they do not want to do is they
do not want to submit to their creator
and have to live within the constructs
of a religion that has tenets of faith
yeah how can the I really don't believe
sincerely deep down to anybody's truly
100% a that everybody deep down even
though they cover it up believes in a
Supreme Being it's just part of our
natural makeup and people cover this up
but how can be that someone who is a
seer now and they want to know more
about atheist ask more questions or
someone wants to invite you out to speak
at their university whatever the case
how they get ahold of you anybody can
contact me through the contact us button
on my website level truth comm there I
have a I have a website specifically for
atheists called reality of God calm and
one for Christians true to Jesus calm
but if you go to level truth calm
go to the site map you will find all of
my websites go to contact us and you
will find me
that easy daddies thank you very much
it's always a pleasure to have you on
the Dean show I got around peace be with
you Salam alaikum virtually all
ourselves
beautiful masha'Allah another exciting
episode on Adi show now come and come in
who you kiddin
look everybody within themselves
believes in a creator look look when
it's real dark out and the Thunder roars
huh oh God
huh you know you've done it because you
believe or you saw a little mouse and
you jump up on the table Oh God or a big
tiger in a jungle or you're in a plane
or out in the sea and the waves are just
taking over Oh God or in a foxhole oh
god help so deep down every human being
believes in the creator but a lot of
times we get distracted we cover it up
and just some common cell sense you know
this way of life that the Creator is
calling us to live it's on pure goodness
everything that he's told us to do is
good and at the end when we die at the
end we have an ultimate reward paradise
but there is an ultimate consequences so
what do you get just following your
desires go ahead and enjoy all the porn
and all the parties and accumulate all
the wealth and the money and then what
what if at the end what we know is real
you come to know it and it's too late to
go back if we die at the end and there's
nothing we have nothing to lose but what
do you have to gain and what do you have
to lose at the end you have everything
to lose when the Hellfire is staring at
your face and you can't go back so these
are the signs that come to you
contemplate and reflect and sincerely
ask the one who created all this this
universe and everything in creation to
guide you and he will facilitate away if
you are sincere and come back to the
Deen show every week we're here with a
new exciting episode subscribe if you
haven't already you have some more
questions call us or visit the website
from our special guest dr. Lawrence
Brown we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you subscribe right now
you